mamma io esco dove vai
devo andare da giulia dobbiamo ri
passare per la verifica di domani
certo certo ogni occasione è buona per
lasciare tua madre a casa da sola anche
quando sta male cosa è come stai male
non ho niente cinquina è sì pure va mai
a divertirti mi puoi dire che cos'hai
che cosa mi sento male o mal di gola mi
sento la testa che gira o la pressione
bassa guarda che fra poco svengo lo vedi
che sto sudando freddo ma tu escì vaghi
se mi sento male chiamo la vicina
se stai male allora resto a casa mamma
presi a casa
brava mamma siediti qua adesso finisco
di pulire e poi ci guardiamo il segreto
tutte insieme
[Musica]
guarda che casino che disordine cose poi
che non li servono neanche di cos'è sta
cosa qui tuttavia aperta po di ordine in
questa stanza ma dove sono le mie casse
ma mai visto le mie casse gas punta
visto casse io ma erano nell'armadio ti
giuro me lo ricordo ascolta io in camera
tua non sono neanche entrata non so
proprio di cosa stai parlando
ma se ti dico che io le avevo messe lì
se ti dico che non sono entrata non sono
entrata va bene vediamo
[Musica]
questa penh dove erano nel cestino mamma
chi le ha messe nel cestino ma guarda
nel cestino
sai che è stato tuo padre già la mania
di buttare via le cose stato lui sì
dove vai mamma vado a fare un giro in
centro con le mie amiche brava brava
con tutte le cose che si sentono in
televisione e tu cosa fai
esci dovresti stare a casa le tue amiche
doversi portare a casa io quando abbiamo
la tua età non sono mai uscita di casa
mai sono sempre a casa con la mia
famiglia perché era una brava vecchiotta
ma se mi hai raccontato che papale
conosciuta in discoteca
io guarda a parte che non mi ricordo
neanche e comunque anche se fosse quando
l'ho conosciuto le discoteche le strade
le città erano sicura non come adesso
che è pieno di maniaci e tutte queste
tragedie che ci sento
secondo me la devi smettere di guardare
chi l'ha visto è pronto ma non è pronto
ma ma io sto morendo di fame è infatti è
quasi pronto fai una cosa va a parecchia
[Musica]
non voglio visitare te e non vuoi perché
prete amia cosa è successo perché a
questa faccia niente mamma di tommy alla
mamma vuoi dire tutto team di giurata
non mi arrabbio
no perché se te lo dico ti arrabbi che
ho detto che non mi arrabbio
la mamma è qui per te per aiutarti dimmi
tutto ho preso tre matematica vieni
vieni che ho detto guarda che non sono
arrabbiata tu vieni tesoro guarda volevo
passare un attimo a salutare l'asia rosa
vieni con me lo studio al e non ho
voglia
poi ogni volta che andiamo li facciamo
notte ma dà anche lo stiamo poco guarda
ti prometto che mezz'oretta e siamo a
casa
se sapessi le cose che dicono in paese
varda lui ha messo i corni già da anni e
due anni dopo il matrimonio già
immetteva i corni in parrocchia non si
parla d'altro ultimamente rosa guarda
una vergogna poreta andare in giro
avevi detto che stava un po ha infatti
siamo stati poco siamo qua solo da due
ore non la vedo mai così a rosa abbiamo
da raccontarci dai che fra poco andiamo
al tie buona su el ora ti stavo dicendo
cioè lei non sapeva niente
[Musica]